>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: TODAY WE LEARNED THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL REREESE
THE REPORT ON THE DOJ AND THE
FBI ONE WEEK FROM TODAY.
THE IG WILL TESTIFY BEFORE THE
SENATE ON THE 18th.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
REPORT WOULD COVER JUST THE
FBI'S INVESTIGATION OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL
BUT THE IG REPORT COULD BE MUCH
BROADER.
GRASSLEY TITLED IT EXAMINING THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S FIRST REPORT
ON JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND FBI
ACTION IN ADVANCE OF THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER.
WITH DARRELL ISSA AND DANIEL
GOLDMAN AND LEE SMITH.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU HAVE BEEN
AROUND THE BLOCK ON THIS STUFF.
WHAT GIVES?
A BROADER REPORT?
WHY WOULD GRASSLEY TITLE IT LIKE
THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL BECAUSE MICHAEL
HOROWITZ HAS BEEN AROUND A LONG
TIME AND DONE A LOT OF
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE PROBLEMS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN
A PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION THAT
WOULD NOT DEAL WITH THOSE
PROBLEMS EVEN WITH REPORTED TO
CONGRESS.
HE WILL BE ASKED QUESTIONS WE
KNOW FROM THE PAST HE CAN SPEAK
ON.
SECONDLY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
INDEMIC MISCONDUCT OF COMEY
INCLUDING THE APPLE SCANDAL
WHERE HE CLAIMED YOU COULD NOT
GET INFORMATION AND IT TURNED
OUT NOT TO BE TRUE OR HANDLING
HILLARY CLINTON.
IT GETS BROAD PRETTY QUICK.
LOOKING AT OTHER DECISIONS
INCLUDING THE FISA WARRANTS.
>> Laura: LEE, LOTS OF THINGS
ARE BUBBLING UP TO THE SURFACE.
THIS LEAK YESTERDAY.
TO SAY THAT COMEY WAS
INSUBORDINATE IS THAT A BIG
BOMBSHELL?
>> MAYBE IT'S BEEN BUILT UP TOO
MUCH.
THERE IS AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT TO
COVER.
THAT'S MAY ANSWER WITH SENATOR
GRASSLEY TITLED THIS.
THE PUBLIC IS KEEN AND KEEPS
HEARING LEAKS AND THIS IS BEING
PUSHED BACK AND THIS IS BEING
BLOCKED.
I THINK THEY ARE EITHER TO GET
OUT A NUMBER OF THESE THINGS
BEFORE IT INTERFERES TOO MUCH
WITH THE ELECTION CYCLE.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY
ISSUES.
>> Laura: ONE ISSUE THAT POPPED
UPSHAW WITH PAPADOPOULOS.
HIS WIFE SAID THEY WERE TRYING
TO ENTRAP HIM AND USE HIM TO
PUSH THIS INVESTIGATION FORWARD.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, LEGALLY IT'S NOT
ENTRAPMENT.
IF THERE IS ANY INDICATION THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL IS WILLING TO DO
WHATEVER THE CONDUCT IT.
I THINK SHE IS USING ANOTHER
DEFINITION OF ENTRAPMENT.
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS MADE SOME
DRUNKEN COMMENT TO THE
AUSTRALIANAMBASSADOR TO THE U.N.
AND THAT SPURRED FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS.
>> Laura: INITIALLY IT WAS
REPORTED THAT HE KNEW THERE WERE
A LOT OF CLINTON EMAILS.
THEN THEY BACKED OFF AND SAID
THEY HAD DIRT ON HILLARY.
THAT STORY SHIFTED.
THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENT, SOMEONE
HAS DIRT ON HILLARY AND SOMEONE
KNEW EMAILS WERE HACKED AND
WOULD BE RELEASED.
>> HAVING SPENT 10 YEARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND HAVING
CASES REPORTED ON BY THE NEWS
MEDIA, ABOUT 50% WAS RIGHT.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
JOURNALIST'S FAULT.
SOMETIMES THE SOURCES ARE TOO
FAR REMOVED.
THEY DON'T HAVE AS MUCH AS THE
INFORMATION AS YOU WOULD LIKE.
LET'S NOT JUMP TO CONCLUSIONS.
THERE WAS SOME INDICATION THAT
PAPADOPOULOS NEW THAT RUSSIA HAD
INFORMATION HE WAS TRYING TO GET
ACCESS TO THAT.
AT THAT POINT IT'S INCUMBENT ON
THE FBI TO INVESTIGATE THAT TO
SEE IF THERE IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK.
>> Laura: YOU DON'T THINK
ANYBODY HAPPENED BEFORE THAT
PERIOD OF TIME?
THE TEXT MESSAGES LOOKING AT
TRUMP AND TALKING THE LURESED
IN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS
ABOUT.
THAT ONE UNREDACTED TEXT.
THAT'S WEIRD STUFF.
MAYBE THAT'S INNOCENT.
MAYBE THEY IS LURES ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FOR YOU
ABOUT THE INFORMANTS.
KEVIN WHO SUPERVISED THE
REVITTING OF THE RULES FOR THE
FBI JOINED US LAST WEEK.
>> AN FBI CAN'T JUST OPEN A
SOURCE AND GATHER INFORMATION.
THEY HAVE TO ABIDE BY THE
GUIDELINES.
THE GUIDELINES ARE SPECIFIC IN
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATIONS AND WHEN YOU ARE
DIRECTING YOUR SOURCE TOWARDS AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
>> Laura: THE GUY WHO REWROTE
THE RULES.
>> WHEN YOU SAID IT'S INCUMBENT,
THAT'S HOG WASH.
THE FACT IS EVERY SINGLE
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, THE SENATE,
HOUSE, PRESIDENTIAL, THEY ARE
ALL LOOKING FOR DIRT.
THEY WANT IT WHEREVER THEY WILL
GET.
IT THEY PAY FOR IT.
THEY HIRE ATTORNEYS.
>> Laura: HILLARY PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER.
>> IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE/FBI INVESTIGATED EVERY
TIME THERE WAS A CREDIBLE
ATTEMPT TO GET DIRT, YOU WOULD
BE INVESTIGATING HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS.
>> COME ON.
IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN THE SOURCE
OF THE INFORMATION IS A FOREIGN
COUNTRY THAN IF THE SOURCE OF
THE INFORMATION IS SOMEONE
WITHIN THE COUNTRY.
>> A VAGUE ALLEGATION THAT THERE
MAY BE SOMETHING IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN WELL, WE HAVE
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
LET'S REMEMBER, IN THIS CASE.
AT SOME POINT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE KNEW THAT THE DNC AND
HILLARY CLINTON WERE PART OF THE
SOURCE OF THAT.
>> LONG BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> I AM UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
IDEA THAT THE FBI IS RUNNING AN
INVESTIGATION BASED ON WHAT A
CAMPAIGN TEAM MEMBER SAID
OVERHEARD IN A BAR.
I THINK THAT'S PECULIAR.
IF WE WENT TO A BAR AND HAD A
CONVERSATION AND I AM ON A
CAMPAIGN AND YOU ARE.
THE FBI SAYS LET'S RUN AN
INVESTIGATION ON THAT GUY, I
THINK THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WANT.
>> Laura: I SEE WHAT LEE IS
SAYING THERE.
ESPECIALLY DURING A CHARGED
POLITICAL SEASON.
THIS WAS GUY WAS LIKE A MINOR
DUDE.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE --
>> Laura: WE DON'T KNOW WHEN IT
STARTED.
>> I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
TIMING.
I WOULD BET MONEY WHEN THEY
STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION, THEY
HAD NO IDEA WHO WAS INVOLVED.
THEY DIDN'T THINK AT THE
BEGINNING IT WENT TO DONALD
TRUMP OR THAT HIGH.
THEY WERE FOLLOWING A LEAD OF A
SUSPICIOUS AND SPECIFIC
STATEMENT THAT GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS GAVE TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
THEY WILL CHASE THAT DOWN AS YOU
WOULD WANT THEM TO DO I THINK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS NOTHING
GOING ON.
>> Laura: THAT TRIP TO LONDON IN
MAY OF 2016, DOES THAT SEEM --
>> IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT THAT IS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
MECHANISM THAT WAS TRANSMITED TO
THE FBI.
THE IDEA IT CAME FROM THE STATE